President Trump says it is time to get
back to work after spending Christmas
day with his family the White House says
the first family spent the day opening
presents at his Florida resort chip Reid
is in West Palm Beach with the
president's to-do list chip good morning
well good morning the president is
already tweeting this morning he says
that because the Obama care individual
mandate was eliminated by the tax bill
he's predicting that Democrats and
Republicans will eventually come
together and develop a great new health
care plan and he says it is now time to
get back to work
my fellow Americans the president and
first lady posted a Christmas message on
Twitter has spent the rest of the day
out of public view with family at their
mar-a-lago estate later the president
tweeted that now it's back to work to
make America great again
this was president Trump shortly before
leaving for Florida I'll be working very
hard during that Christmas because we
have many things were talking about
including North Korea including a lot of
things happening in the Middle East that
includes confronting the international
backlash that followed the president's
controversial decision to move the US
Embassy in Israel to Jerusalem Jerusalem
is Israel's capital that decision drew
broad condemnation at the United Nations
last week on Sunday Guatemala announced
their embassy would also move to
Jerusalem over the objection of
Palestinian leaders on Monday Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
predicted that many other nations will
do the same but 2018 won't just be a
year of foreign policy hurdles the
president also faces domestic challenges
including the possibility of a partial
government shutdown if Congress does not
act by January 19th the White House
would also like to pursue welfare reform
and another major campaign promise a
bipartisan infrastructure package
infrastructure is by far the easiest
people wanted Republicans and Democrats
we're gonna have tremendous Democrat
support and infrastructure despite all
the talk of the president getting back
to work there is nothing on his schedule
today and when we asked the White House
who he'll be meeting with or talking to
over the
they would only tell us quote we will
keep you all posted over the next
several days
Dana chip Reid with the president chip
thank you